laayo l'artère principale cette rue
comme toute la ville vit du couteau et
pour le couteau de laayole bien sûr un
marché important on en vend 600000
chaque année de quoi aiguiser les
appétits chaque boutique commercialise
le véritable couteau de la yole
différent de celui en vente dans la
boutique suivante chacun se prétendant
seul garant du respect de la tradition
pierre calmer c'est pourtant le seul à
pouvoir dire qu'il est l'arrière
Petitfils du créateur du laayol nous
continuons à assurer artisanalement la
tradition et nous avons certains secrets
de
fabrication que l'on ne sait qu'en
famille tout allait bien pour le petit
commerce jusqu'en 1988 un avéronnais qui
a réussi à Paris Jean-Louis cost créer
une société qui fabriquera du la Yol à
la yo les Bâ sont dessinés par celui qui
recrée ce qu'on ne sait plus voir
Philipp Stark il remodèlera aussi le
couteau ce couteau que tout le monde
croit connaître et dont on avait oublié
de déposer la marque oublie réparé objet
redessiné mission accomplie par Philipp
Stark pas banal d'autant que son couteau
si si c'est le sien est sélectionné par
le Comité Colbert comme étant un des 10
objets de la
décennie le travail de revisite comme je
viens de le dire c'est un travail de de
de
comment estimer quelle est l'essence du
produit quelle est son âme le garder et
l'amplifier le
décupler par un nettoyage des détails
inutiles avec un objet comme ça on se
retrouve avec réellement l'histoire et
la vérité d'un vrai vrai produit d'usage
mais
complètement adapté à notre vie et à
notre esprit d'aujourd'hui à la comme
avant dans l'usine on forge on trempe on
Martelle les trois versions du couteau
l'â seu l'â et poinçon l'â poinon et
tirebouchon ou encore le modèle visité
par un parisien pour autant personne ne
voit de rupture avec le
passé pour nous c'est un objet qui
représente bien autre chose qu'un
couteau et c'est la raison pour laquelle
on tenait à la fabriquer ici laol d'une
façon traditionnelle chacun à la savait
que les couteaux avonis étai fabriqués à
dans le puit dome jusqu'à l'implantation
de la nouvelle usine un seul a osé en
parler le maire depuis il a perdu son
siège mais c'est sûrement
hasard